all know the words and it certainly
gives you goosebumps especially nate
when you think about what's going on in
ukraine tony is with us again he's at
the polish border with ukraine he's in
the village of a place called medica as
we've been talking about tony is
tracking the endless streams of people
who are fleeing the war
tony good morning to you the numbers are
just staggering when you see the people
crossing that border
gail good morning the numbers are
staggering and so are the distances in
just the last few minutes here we've
been monitoring the continued arrival of
refugees and just a few moments ago i
took a walk down there and talked to a
few and the wave that we're seeing now
is coming from kharkiv a town that was
in the headlines last week it is 700
miles away that gives you an idea of how
vast the journey really is to safety
here in poland it is freezing and as i
mentioned in the last hour we've seen
mothers on their knees feeding their
children hot soup before it too goes
cold we have a picture of that i wanted
to show you
it's one of those shots here that really
gets it
it hits me every time and the question
that everybody in that line behind me
has
is when is this going to end so some
news on that front the u.s is sending
not only humanitarian aid but also
lethal weaponry and we have seen some of
it moving through poland just today
multiple giant aircraft including air
force c-17s
landing at an airstrip about an hour
away from where we're standing
that aircraft you see there that is the
type that's been carrying javelin
anti-tank missiles and stinger
anti-aircraft missiles which then make
their way over the border into ukraine
to help the ukrainian fight against the
russians and we also saw on the way to
this location this morning a convoy of
u.s
of military vehicles with boxes with u.s
markings on them they too were headed
toward the border as for the fighting
itself this morning there's another
attempt at a ceasefire we liked the
sound of that but there were failed
attempts over the weekend which once
again left civilians forced to shelter
to avoid russian shelling
but something we noticed as well as
others flee some are heading into the
fight on last night's 60 minutes you may
have seen scott pelley's report and his
conversation with some ukrainian men
currently living outside of ukraine who
were making the journey back into the
country to join the fight they see
themselves as defenders of their country
but also defenders of democracy
and tomorrow we'll have more on that on
cbs mornings we'll show you it's not
only ukrainians going to join the fight
but americans as well traveling here to
cross over and join the fight a fight
they see as one for democracy this
border here gail innate is no longer
just a border between two countries but
for many it's being described now as the
eastern front of the free world
yeah we've been hearing that tony people
who have never held a gun before never
been in a war zone or saying i'm going
put me in thank you very much tony we'll
check back in with you a little bit
later on